Good morning, Hank.
It's Tuesday.
The Paper Towns movie finished shooting a
couple days ago so I am home.
I'm tired and a little bit sick, and as you
can probably hear, my voice has been rode
hard and put away wet, but I'm happy to be
home and am so grateful to everybody who worked
so hard on the Paper Towns movie.
So Hank, this is a map of New York created
by the General Drafting Company for the gas
station Esso.
I suppose I should explain for our younger
viewers that this is essentially like a static
version of Google Maps printed on a very large
sheet of paper.
But anyway, this particular map is interesting
because where— wait, where are you?
Ah!
There you are.
So this map is kind of famous to cartography
nerds and also to readers of Paper Towns because
just north of a little town called Rockland,
New York, it contains Agloe, New York.
Agloe was a town made up by the two guys who
created this map, Ernest G Alpers and Otto
Lindbergh.
They took their initials together, mixed them
up, and made Agloe.
And then they put their little fake town in
the middle of nowhere, at the intersection
of two dirt roads in the Catskills.
They did this to protect their copyright.
Mapmakers have always created these little
'paper towns' or 'paper streets' so if they
see them on someone else's map, they'll know
that they've been robbed.
Anyway, flash forward like forty years after
the first General Drafting map with Algoe,
New York on it, Rand McNally makes a map with
Agloe, New York on it.
And when General Drafting calls Rand McNally
to be like "We're gonna sue you" Rand McNally
says, "NONONONO!
Agloe is real!"
Because people kept going to that intersection
of two dirt roads in the middle of nowhere,
expecting a place called Agloe, someone built
a place called Agloe.
Essentially, Hank, the story of Agloe, New
York is the story of a fiction that became
real.
Now, I would argue that this happens to fictions
and constructions all the time, like I remember
one time in college I told one of my professors
that things that are constructed aren't really
real, and my professor was like, "Well, this
chair is constructed, but if I hit you with
it, it is going to hurt."
The truth is, Hank, the way we imagine the
world does end up shaping reality.
And the book Paper Towns is about how we hurt
ourselves and each other when we imagine other
people as less than human or more than human.
But I guess what interests me most is the
way that our incomplete imaginings of people
and their incomplete imaginings of us end
up shaping our lives really profoundly.
So anyway, back in 2008 I published a story
about how like the merely imagined can, in
my opinion, become really real.
And then Agloe, New York, which had originally
been fictional and then became real and then
sort of fell into disrepair and disappeared
again, kind of became real again.
Readers started making pilgrimages to Agloe,
they found the site of the former Agloe general
store, one of them even made a fake historical
marker which, I guess, come to think of it,
is kind of a real historical marker?
And then, six years later, largely thanks
to readers continuing to care about Q and
Margo and Agloe, people in Hollywood decided
to make a movie, and it all became real again,
in a way.
I got to meet all of these people that I'd
imagined and go inside of their houses and
visit Agloe, New York with them.
Hank, the journey of this to this has been
the weirdest and most wonderful part of what
has been a very weird and wonderful year for
me, personally.
So I just wanted to take a second to thank
everyone who's made Paper Towns real by virtue
of reading it and, in turn, made Agloe real
again.
Of course, I know that Agloe will, again,
cease to exist someday, as everything does.
But I think it's pretty cool that, together,
we've made it real for awhile.
Thanks for that.
I can't even begin to explain what a gift
it's been for me.
Hank, I'll see you on Friday.